it all right u.s intelligence officials
tell cbs news that china is trying to
collect
americans dna in hopes of controlling
the future of health care
60 minutes correspondent john wertheim
talked to career intelligence official
bill
evan nina and supervisory special agent
edward yu
about how china is trying to collect
americans medical data
and why this may pose a threat to
national security
we have probably five or six health care
companies the last five years
who have been i would say penetrated
exfiltrated hacked by china what's the
likelihood you and i have been hacked by
china
110 personal data
personal data current estimates are that
80 percent of american adults have had
all their personally identifiable
information
stolen by the communist party of china
the concern is that the chinese regime
is taking all that information about us
what we eat how we live when we exercise
and sleep
and then combining it with our dna data
with information about heredity and
environment suddenly
they know more about us than we know
about ourselves and
bypassing doctors china can target us
with treatments and medicine
we don't even know we need think about
the dawn of
the internet of things and the 5g
networks and smart homes and smart
cities
they're going to be sensors everywhere
it's going to be tracking your movement
your behavior
habits and ultimately it's going to have
a biological application meaning
that based on the data that gets
collected they'll be able to analyze it
and look at
improving your health that data becomes
incredibly relevant
and very very valuable you're describing
data almost as a
as a commodity data is absolutely going
to be the new oil
and john wertham joins us now john take
us into the future here if china has all
this information 110
chance we've already been hacked how
worried should we be
terrified
um yeah i mean i think what intelligence
officials told us is really
it's two-pronged one is financial that
if china has
all of this information that is so
valuable that's a huge financial benefit
china's been very upfront they want to
dominate biotech by 2025 the global
sphere four trillion dollar industry
if you have a huge dna library if you
have all this data that's incredibly
valuable
the other threat is a national security
threat and just thinking about how much
information another country
has on us think about how that could be
used for surveillance for instance
uh yeah i mean talking to the national
intelligence officials we spoke with
they
feel like this is a an imminent threat
yes and john the flip side of terrified
is there something to celebrate here
potentially what's the concern
if china calls up one day and says hey
we've got your dna and watch out there's
trouble ahead for you healthcare wise
yeah i mean there is undeniable benefit
to this potentially but one of the
concerns is that
china will be able to essentially end
run our health care system they will
know so much
about us and we'll be able to target
customers directly hey we know this
about you we know about your spending we
know about your your sleep habits but
now we also are able to combine that
with all the knowledge we have
about your health data about your dna
they could cut out the pharmaceutical
industry they could cut out health care
and i think that having that
exist offshore is something that
concerned again the the intelligence
sources we spoke with
john it's not just the chinese of course
i mean there are american companies like
23 and me and anne's respree
which collect your dna when you give
them information hoping to find
family members around the country what's
what's the potential risk
of sharing that with them
i i guess the most obvious risk is
financial i mean your dna is very
valuable
and people we spoke would say i'm not
sure all americans understand that so
you're providing for free something
that has immense value for these
companies and for their partnerships
then there are privacy concerns these
genealogy companies have been hacked
and a lot of this is just we don't know
how this is going to go in the future
this is this is fluid space this is uh
this is a fast-moving sector
and what seems like fairly innocuous
today
may have a much more sinister much more
sinister implications in the future
there are i mean let's be clear too
there is undeniable good that can come
out of this i mean this
uh this is where treatments and cures
are going to come from in the future but
the concern that was voiced to us again
and again are people just
don't quite understand what they're
signing up for we should point out that
ancestry told 60 minutes that it does
not sell data
and any data shared is anonymous 23andme
ceo told you that her com
that her company does not share
information unless customers opt in
but people john a lot of people in this
country are used to voluntarily sharing
information
in exchange for getting some service
back
that came up in our reporting that ann
wojcicki that the ceo of 23andme so look
80 of our customers they are signing in
they are giving informed consent for us
to use their dna use their data for
research and we had a number of
bioethics bioethicists some law
professors that
were skeptical of that and said exactly
what you say that uh we're used to
hitting okay
when we get that app when we make that
online purchase that doesn't mean that
we've necessarily
read the fine print do people know
exactly what they're signing
into yeah i think most of them would say
they don't
john wertheim thank you very much